BOB MEESE: Thank you for coming
to the Games panel today.
The overall topic is
around bringing your games
internationally.
And so we have five
fine gentlemen here
who will tell you some stories.
I want to make this as
interactive as possible, too,
so if there are anything that
you guys want to hear about,
we have a mic that we'll
bring around as well, too.
So we can take
questions at any point.
This time is for
all of you today.
And we had a nice, lively email
exchange leading up to this.
So we definitely have some
opinions on the panel.
But a great group of guys.
So if you guys have any other
questions or topics to suggest,
please do that.
But just first want to start off
by having these guys just spend
30 seconds just
introducing themselves,
their company, and then
any specific experience
around bringing your games
to international markets,
just to kind of introduce
everybody at the start here.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Hi, everyone.
I'm Saad Choudri from Miniclip.
We're probably best known in the
app stores for "8 Ball Pool."
So if you haven't played
that, check it out.
We also publish James
Vaughan's "Plague Inc"--
I'll give him a shout,
because he's right there--
on the Android platform.
And because we started
as a Flash games website
14 years ago and transitioned
over to mobile about four years
ago, we've always been
global and bringing
content to the
world the moment we
deployed it, because
we started on browser.
We never had any of
those issues from trying
to work in the console days and
bring them to different-- NTSC
to PAL, for instance.
And the way we would
do that is by trying
to keep the language very--
as few strings as possible
and keep it very graphical.
And we've continued to do
that in mobile as well.
And we can discuss as we
talk how we've done that.
BOB MEESE: Good.
Thanks a lot.
JOE RAEBURN: Hello, everybody.
My name is Joe Raeburn.
I'm a producer at
Space Ape Games.
We make "Samurai Siege," which
is a relatively popular combat
strategy game.
We are live globally.
We're about to go live
in Korea specifically.
We had a unique
challenge in that
we were a team of
just 10 people.
We got together to
make a game, where
we wanted to take on Supercell
and the rest of the world.
And one of the things
that we had about our game
is it's actually a
Japanese-themed combat strategy
game.
We had some naysayers
saying there's
no way that a
bunch of Westerners
can take a Japanese-themed
combat strategy game
and launch it in Japan.
You must be crazy.
And so for a while we let
these guys psych ourselves out.
We'd done all of
the basic stuff,
like in terms of basic hygiene
for localization, what Hyunse
says in his presentation is
perfect-- just take that, get
the notes, follow it, but
don't psych yourselves out.
Don't listen to people who
say your game won't work.
Human beings are
fundamentally wired the same.
Our brains are identical all
the way around the world.
There are layers of culture
that you need to pierce through,
but as long as you get through
them and you have a good game,
your game will succeed.
So this game that people
said, they'll never
like this Western Japanese game
in Japan, in fact has over 50%
day one retention in Japan.
Monetization is twice what
it is in the United States,
and the game's performing
incredibly well.
So don't listen
to the naysayers.
Get the basic facts right.
Launch your game.
Success!
EYAL RABINOVICH: OK.
Is it working?
BOB MEESE: Not yet.
EYAL RABINOVICH: So my name is
Eyal, and I'm from Playscape.
We publish games since 2008.
And I'm managing the Marketing
and the Business Development
activities.
We have about 50
games in the market.
70 million downloads.
And when it comes to
launching the games,
we always do it globally.
So localization is a big issue.
Our approach is just
try to stay as much
data-driven as possible.
And I'm sure we can talk
about it in this panel.
And that's it.
BOB MEESE: Thanks.
ANATOLY ROPOTOV: Let me
see if this is working.
OK, my name is Anatoly, and
I'm CEO of Game Insight.
Game Insight is a global game
developer, cross-platform one.
We have over 30 games,
250 million players.
And the biggest challenge for
us once we enter the new market
is to ensure that we
could smoothly roll out
at least six to seven and
even more games in operation.
Our biggest genre is SIM/Tycoon
and Hidden Object, so a lot
of story-driven, a
lot of localization,
a lot of tailoring the
content for local markets.
And our approach is typically to
tie in the launch of the games
with some local
festive activity,
so it'll be either holidays,
or some kind of events.
Let's say, if it's
Brazil, it would
be either Carnival or a
football championship,
to really say that we
thinking about local players
and thinking about the market
and committing ourselves
to deliver the best community
management and a lot
of different practices
for that market.
ANTONIN LHUILLIER: Hello.
I'm Antonin.
I work for Gameloft
on the business side.
I manage, among others,
business offices in Moscow,
in London, Berlin, Copenhagen,
so what we call North Europe.
And I'm in charge also of
the partnership with Google
at [? TMA ?] level.
So we launch all
our games globally.
We localize in 16 languages.
We have lately started
localizing our games
in Arabic language, Indonesian,
Thai, traditional Chinese.
So when we have a
lot of local teams,
we make sure that the launch
of our localized games
succeed in each territory.
So, in particular, we are
very-- as Anatoly said,
we do a lot of in-game events
tailored to local players.
We also make sure that we
address the local media.
We know the local
media landscape,
including in some cases the
specific social networks that
are strong in a given country.
Like in Korea, for
instance, you need
to work with Kakao
or in some cases
to integrate Kakao inside
your games to succeed.
Or you need also to
address your players
through VKontakte in Russia.
BOB MEESE: Cool.
Thanks, everybody.
So one of the baselines that
we've started to talk about
is around localization.
I've talked with
some of you guys,
too, in terms of there's many
different languages that you're
localizing into.
If you're not a native
speaker, though, it
can be hard to understand
is this any good?
I'm curious if you guys
have thoughts or just
any suggestions
in terms of how do
you know when your
localization is good enough?
Do you need a native speaker
for all of those languages?
Or how do you guys
make that determination
in terms of when your
localization for a given
language is good enough
to put it out there?
JOE RAEBURN: I'm
going to take that
from a small studio perspective.
So what we do is, we make sure
that we have excellent customer
support in place when we launch.
So customer support is key.
It's kind of just
like Hyunse said,
good App Store descriptions,
really, really good
localizations, and making sure
that you have local customer
support on the ground.
Get local customer support on
the ground relatively early so
that they can start gearing
up and understanding the game.
And those same guys,
if they're on board
and they're part
of your company,
and they're playing your
game trying to understand it,
what we did is we used them
as a final layer of QA.
So what we're actually
doing for our new project
is we're doing something
like an AB test.
So we're taking one
small sliver of the game
that we know and we
understand, and we
know that will stay the same.
We're putting that out to
four different localization
providers.
And we're assigning the
customer support agent
that role of playing
through it in those four
different languages or those
four different translations
and saying, this
one's the best, but it
needs this little
bit of feedback.
So because we knew that
customer support agent anyhow
and because they need to
understand the game anyhow,
we're essentially
getting this final level
of localization choice for free.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Joe, do you
guys hire people specifically
in each country?
Or do you outsource
that customer support?
JOE RAEBURN: So
we've got a system
where we give each
language the level of love
that we want to give it.
So Japanese and
Korean, for example,
they are huge, huge markets.
So we want to hire one person
specifically for each of those.
Some of the European
languages, like, for example,
we are not doing
so great in Spain,
and we have a few people.
And Brazilian Portuguese
is quite good for us.
But we might find someone in
Europe, someone from a player
base who really wants
to come on board that
can speak two or
three languages.
And we're like,
great; we'll have you.
So we try to double
up on the languages
where the revenue isn't so high
but have dedicated customer
support for languages where
the revenue is very high.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Cool.
I only say that
because there's going
to be studios in here who have
varying amounts of ability
to actually hire people on the
ground in these territories,
which are clearly high value.
We saw the presentation of
where revenue's coming from.
But to answer the
question, it's reviews.
It's user feedback.
If you can start seeing your
rating go down all of a sudden
once you've pushed out a
language localization build
and you've not changed
anything else for the game,
and it was doing well
before, you probably
messed up translation somewhere.
So that's probably
the best indicator.
BOB MEESE: That's
the negative signal.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Yeah, exactly.
But if it's good, then
you get good feedback.
You get your account managers
in each country saying, yeah,
that's really good,
and it's well done.
And to be honest, we leverage
our platform contacts, who
will say, yep,
you're doing well.
That makes sense.
The example I used
in our email, Fred,
was, for instance, pool
means nothing in Turkey.
It just doesn't mean anything.
But that's what our game
is called out there.
So we were told by a fan that
no, it's American billiards.
That's what you actually
need to call it.
And it's still English.
You don't even have to change
into the Turkish language
string.
It's just you have
to name it what
people know that game to be.
And I think, Joe, you
mentioned something
about the negative
connotation of samurai.
JOE RAEBURN: Yeah, because
of the Sino-Japanese War,
samurai isn't always perceived
with the most positive
connotations.
What we heard from
our research--
and I'm probably going to
be corrected by someone
who knows it better--
was that about one
out of four people
in Korea would
have a vaguely negative
reaction to the word "samurai."
So what we actually
did is, in Japan
it's called "Samurai Big War."
We came up with a slightly
different translation
in English, changed
that into Korean,
bounced it off our
translation company
and bounced it off our Korean
customer support people.
And they said, that
name is awesome.
so we went with that.
EYAL RABINOVICH: So I
think the biggest operation
we had when it came to
translating the games
and localizing them
was when we had
a deal with NTT DoCoMo in Japan.
And they basically asked
us to take 100 games
and to localize them,
which we thought,
yes, OK, we can do that.
But it wasn't that easy.
It's so much more than
just translating the text,
even if all you want to do
is just translate the text.
So using QA is always advisable.
We had a local partner in Japan.
So if you can have that,
I think that's amazing
because they can play the game.
They can give you
direct feedback.
You have someone
to talk to, which
is-- I think it might be more
advisable than just releasing
the game to the
market, then starting
to see your rating go down.
Each point's so painful.
So that's what we did in Japan.
And when it comes to working
with translation companies,
you can always ask
them to also add
QA, which means
they'll play the game
and see that everything
was added properly.
So just do that.
I think that's a
good investment.
BOB MEESE: Cool.
ANATOLY ROPOTOV:
At Game Insight,
it's a big challenge for
us to run a lot of events
and localize a lot of
content on a bi-weekly basis.
So we employ combined approach
of having in-house localization
teams across Europe.
We have some people in Germany.
We have in-house French
community management.
Our HQ's in Lithuania and
Riga, in Baltic states,
where it's easy for us to
handle operations in Russia.
So we combine all that
approach out there,
but definitely it's a
big challenge for us
with a lot of Eastern
European teams
to localize that in
different languages.
So first of all, those
teams would typically think,
let's say, in Russian.
So we have a lot of US people
in house who take that content
and make it appropriate
for global markets.
And then this content would
be delivered to other markets.
So for us, it's a challenge
to let those teams know
how they should
perceive the world.
Train them in global
events across the world.
Explain to them
socially acceptable
practices across the world,
anything from perception
of vulgarity to
things like that.
And surprisingly, it's sometimes
a challenge to explain that.
But yeah, that's our approach.
BOB MEESE: Could you
speak a little bit, too,
for some of the
bigger companies,
just the amount of investment
in terms of the number of people
that are working on
some of these things?
ANATOLY ROPOTOV: Yeah, so for
localization and translation
teams and in-house proofreading
and things like that,
it's in tens of people in house.
For markets like Asia, we
typically partner with someone
to work with us.
As a cross-platform
developer, we
have a big advantage
of, let's say,
going into social network in
Japan, working with a partner,
and then reusing all
that localization
and great content
that is typically
super hard to produce without
having those people in house
and to plan into our mobile
games in cross-platform manner,
and we see great
results with that.
But we would like to expand
that and build a better
team to serve the
Asian market as well.
We're working in that direction.
BOB MEESE: Thanks.
ANTONIN LHUILLIER:
Yeah, so at Gameloft,
we have resources
in-house for localization.
And we also have localization
QA teams, especially
for, let's say, more
difficult languages,
like Japanese, Korean,
and also Russian.
Russian is quite
demanding, because you
need as much text as
English, if not more.
And the characters weigh a
bit more in terms of bytes.
So in some cases, we need
to stretch the translation
very much, because our games
are initially made English.
So we need to add
Russian text to stick
to the limits which
are I'm in the games.
There are specific parts of the
games, like buttons and so on,
where you need sometimes to
go for a translation which
is not as good as another one.
But it fits the limits.
BOB MEESE: Cool.
One other thing, too.
We talked about localization
versus culturalization, right?
So making more significant
changes to the game
beyond just translating.
And so it seems like there's
a couple different opinions
across this group, too.
So anybody with a
particularly strong opinion
in terms of either
culturalization is appropriate,
or it doesn't work?
And it can certainly differ
by type of game, as well, too.
But just on this topic
of culturalization,
anybody who wants to
talk about whether you're
for it or against it for
your particular games.
SAAD CHOUDRI: I
don't want it to seem
like it's just binary
going down the thing.
BOB MEESE: Yep.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Then
also, if people--
it's the last session of the
day, when most of us know--
BOB MEESE: Grab a drink, yeah.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Just jump in.
BOB MEESE: Yeah.
SAAD CHOUDRI: For us,
culturalization isn't just
the art style, isn't
just the pricing.
It's actually the
live operations.
It's the events.
It's when you do the
push notifications.
It's like people were saying,
in Korea, it's after meal times,
or it's when
they're on the Tube.
I've often said that actually,
the best time for gaming
in the UK would be during
the commuting hours as well,
but we don't have good
Wi-Fi in the Tube.
So that could all change.
So for us, culturalization
is crucial.
But as a company that needs
to, obviously, make profit,
it's very difficult for us
to invest in these countries,
because you have to
ramp up new offices.
You have to find
trustworthy partners.
So we do go and look
for the best people
to work with in each territory.
And then it's still a lot of
resources on your company.
You still have to support that.
You still have a
producer looking at that.
And it's quite difficult,
because that producer
isn't the expert in
that market, which
is why you're using those guys.
It's just a lot of trust.
And you then don't know
if it's going to do well.
There's track records.
And most of us will be trying
to look at the APAC region,
because it's probably the
most difficult for us all
to penetrate-- apart from Joe,
who seems to have smashed it
out of the park with
his "Samurai Siege."
But we have to
culturalize it and not
look like just localization.
Because if you want to
really extract value
from these regions,
players demand it,
because there's so
much content out there.
And if you won't do it, then
a domestic player will do it.
So, yeah I think
you have to look
at what works best for you.
If you can do it
in-house, great.
But the easiest method
is a local partner.
And there's different ways
to cut that up and figure out
a deal that works
for your company.
JOE RAEBURN: So I'm going
to talk about a funny story,
not from us.
But it's from when we
tried to get a better
Japanese localization,
because our first one, someone
looked at it and said,
that's just rubbish.
That will never fly.
They then told us a
story about this game.
It was to do with, I
think, some farm animals.
They'd got a really, really
bad localization partner.
It was translated
into Japanese, but it
was like broken Japanese.
It made absolutely no sense.
But then they just
shipped it anyway.
And they shipped it, and it
was all about these little farm
animals.
And the game did
really, really well,
because players
laughed at it and said,
this Western art
style is so funny.
They all talk in
such a funny way.
They're such funny,
funny characters.
And they're so cute.
So I guess the moral of
that that you can take away
is ultimately what really
matters are your stats.
If you're not looking at your
day one retention, if you're
not looking at your
day seven retention,
if you're not looking
at your monetization,
at your reviews,
then you're not looking
at the right stuff.
And there might
be one, like, I'd
love to say, yes,
fully culturalize
your game for every single
territory out there.
With unlimited manpower,
with a 6,000-person company,
I highly recommend
that's what you do.
If you've got a team
of 15 people trying
to make a difference,
then you really
have to pick your battles.
And what we saw when we
translated into Japanese
is it was just one
thing that really
wasn't cutting the mustard.
If you've ever logged into a
game like "Rage of Bahamut"
or any similar games,
you know that there
are lots and lots
of live events.
When you log in,
you see something
that looks like a web page--
because effectively it
is a web page-- and it will say
something like, 17th of August!
19th of August!
Special event!
Exclamation point,
exclamation point.
That's actually a very,
very distinct coded language
in the way that they talk
about events in Japan.
And we run a lot of live events
in our game "Samurai Siege."
We looked at Asian
games for inspiration.
And we wanted to be able
to do that in the West,
and they just weren't getting
communicated correctly.
And again, our Japanese
customer support
person said, let me just
take what you've got
and mock it up in Photoshop.
And although event
screens are normally
kind of like-- not HTML, but
a template-driven environment
where you put translated
text over the top,
and it renders it
in-game in Arial
or whatever font
we're using, we just
decided to do single
images for Japan
that she made in Photoshop, and
she copy-pasted it in there.
And then the response to
those event pages went way up.
And then we tried it on Japanese
players, and they're like,
you know what?
There's not really anything
that's wrong with what
you're doing.
And so we went, OK,
let's launch it.
On the thing around
notifications,
I think there's been a lot of
underlying theme of designing
for people's lives.
And essentially, that's
designing for humans.
If you think about
when is the right time
to push someone, yes, if
you're going to send out
a bulk push to your
entire customer base,
then doing it at 2:00 AM is
a really, really bad move.
You're not going to
get too many responses.
But if you start thinking about,
how does my notification system
work?
And how does it
take into account
what time-- the players
playing patterns?
Like if they always
log in at 7:00 AM,
then maybe the notification
should come at 6:59 AM
to match up with what
their schedule is.
You don't need to have 200
producers, or 20 producers,
or 10 producers looking at
what the right times are
in each country.
You have analytics and
data and player patterns.
And you can just create nice
human-centric scheduling
things that work for humans.
And you'll find
that generally they
will work for humans
all the world around.
And find what the exceptions
are and fix the exceptions,
and you'll end up
culturalizing a few things
rather than
culturalizing everything.
EYAL RABINOVICH:
So I think there
are two main approaches when
it comes to localization.
You can, first of all,
decide which countries
you want to localize your
game to, select the top 10,
and localize before
you launch the game.
And you can also start launching
the game in one language,
and see which one catches up,
and just translate and localize
as you go.
This is the way even GooglePlay
recommends you to do that.
They give you
suggestions whenever
they see that you
have a user base that
grows in a specific country.
And the second approach is a
little bit more data-driven.
But it also means
that you're going
to launch a game
that is not fully
baked for a specific language.
So there are pros and cons
for each one of those.
The second thing I would
like you to think about
is the fact that you're going
to localize the game for top 10
languages, but you're not
going to be able to localize it
to all the languages
you have in your game.
Just too costly, and
the operational costs
are also something
to be considered.
So you're going to have
a big category of players
that are considered to be in the
"other" category that are going
to play a version of your game.
And you have to think
about how that version is
going to look like.
I don't think that necessarily
going for an English version
would be the right choice.
So what we have been
doing is we started
to think about how
we can globalize
a version of the game.
It will be played by people
that don't necessarily
speak English, but we are
not likely to localize
the game for.
And actually, it shows
us really good results,
both in retention
and in monetization.
And so I think you have
to be kind of flexible
and mix different
approaches if you
want to be able to scale up.
It's not something that--
there's no paradigm.
And sometimes you
localize the game,
and it doesn't show any results.
BOB MEESE: Could you
repeat that, too?
Because you shared a really
good visual earlier, too,
in terms of what that solution
was for the other group.
Could you talk about
that a little more?
EYAL RABINOVICH: Yeah, so
basically it's really simple.
And what's nice about
it is that globalization
doesn't take a lot of
resources because you
don't have to have translations.
What you have to do
is to think about what
are the strings in
your game that you
can replace with
intuitive icons.
And by the way, even if the
icons are not very intuitive,
it's sometimes just good
to put them out there.
If they're not taking a
prominent part of the game,
people will just click on it
later on and see what it does.
So we took the main menu
of "Ninja Chicken," which
is one of our more
successful franchises,
and we just replaced
a few of the buttons
with icons that we
thought that made sense.
And after doing
so, we actually saw
that some of the
English-speaking segments,
actually, even react better
to these modifications.
So it's kind of
interesting to see
how people react
to casual games.
I think it's
specifically-- I mean,
you can do it with casual games.
I don't think that mid-core
games and hard-core games
would be suitable
for this approach.
But if you have a game that
is not very text-intensive,
I think you should
be able to think
about how you do it that way.
ANATOLY ROPOTOV: We employ
some data-driven practices
to figure out if certain
countries performing less,
is performing worse than others.
So just looking at things
like the total completion
rates, retention rates
for that country,
is kind of a signal
to figure out
if something is wrong with
localization or content
approach, and things like that.
And then I would
definitely benchmark
against English
and Russian, which
would be always perfect for
us, and we would figure out
if something is
wrong here and there.
And the coolest thing in the
Google Developer Console,
that a lot of times it
gives signals, and talks
about this region
is starting to grow,
but you actually don't
have localization for that.
For some of the
games, we would launch
with few languages in beta.
For some others, we would
definitely go all in
and say seven, eight, at least,
languages, up to even 10.
But then it all
really comes down
to whether these
countries could monetize
with this type of games.
If, let's say, female
players in a certain country
have those payment methods.
They have debit cards,
and the couldn't use them.
So you have to be really
careful about that.
You have to go region
by region and figure out
if certain localization is
appropriate for that region.
But it's sometimes a challenging
to localize some of our games,
like hidden-object
games, because
for hidden-object games,
it's a huge challenge
to create the glossary with
visual things out there.
So people would definitely
identify a single word
with a shape, with
an image out there.
And if a localization
team doesn't
have a great visual glossary,
let's say, this is a glass,
or this is a mirror,
and they would just
localize a word without
actually looking at the object
and perceiving the context
of the subject in the game,
we would definitely see a
game performing really bad.
And we would have to throw
out the full localization
and go from scratch and explain
to the localization team
how to approach that.
So definitely, different
games and genres
have different approach for us.
And in a lot of countries,
it's a challenge
to have social context and
to achieve as good results
as in other countries.
ANTONIN LHUILLIER: So I
said that the first step
for culturalization is
also your portfolio,
because you need some games.
I mean, they won't
work in some places.
So we see that when we launched,
for instance, "Spiderman
Unlimited," it works greatly
in the UK and the US.
And players from
other territories
won't necessarily maybe
not even know Spiderman.
I don't know, but
it's an IP which--
SAAD CHOUDRI: How
is that possible?
Everybody knows Spiderman.
ANTONIN LHUILLIER:
So far, and in some
territories, we
basically feel that you
need to go really to localize
the business model also,
as Rahim said before.
So, for instance, in Japan--
and also the session on Korea
was interesting from
this point of view--
is there is [INAUDIBLE], so we
have tweaked some of our games
to make them fit
the monetization
habits of some customers.
So let's say that's the
very first step that we take
at Gameloft to be
a global player is
to have a very wide
portfolio of titles
and to try to please
to any customer,
to have something for everyone.
BOB MEESE: Cool.
Any other questions
from the audience?
We can keep going but-- sure.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
about community translations?
Is it too risky, or it's a good
way to engage with the users?
BOB MEESE: So the question
is just what do they
think about community
translations?
Is it a good way to engage
with users or too risky?
SAAD CHOUDRI: We get probably
in the general emails
where people say, hey,
I'm from random country
X. I love your game.
I want to translate it.
I think there will be a
really big market for it.
It's one of those things
that comes down to trust.
He could be a language
professor at a university.
We have had that.
But we've still not gone through
the process, because sometimes,
the truth is, it's
just that market for us
hasn't really got
the traction that we
need to justify doing it.
So somebody in the
community could
do the language localization
and get it out there,
but again, it's time, effort,
and resources, really,
that comes down to it.
But why not?
It could be good.
Try it.
Check it out.
BOB MEESE: We don't
need to test everybody.
Anybody have a
different point of view?
Anybody in favor of
community translation?
ANATOLY ROPOTOV:
Well, as our games
are being updated
every few weeks here
and there, it's kind
of hard to stick
to a single
outsourced person who
likes the game enough
to localize it,
perhaps for a month or two.
But I think this applies more
to in the casual single-player
games, it could
be localized once,
and then the developer
would definitely see benefit
from sales from this region.
He could approach blogs in that
region, and things like that.
But so far, we
haven't done that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BOB MEESE: Could you get a mic?
Can you pass a mic?
All right.
AUDIENCE: So we use
Crowdin to handle
some crowd-sourced
localizations,
and it's actually
been very helpful.
It's a good way to just hit the
languages which you wouldn't
really bother doing otherwise.
So a lot of the
Nordic countries,
English works fine for us.
But then we've got
about 5,000 people
who have been working
on translating
the game into multiple
different languages.
There's no cost to it, except
for it costs $20 a month
or something to
set up the system.
And as long as you
have an automated way
to handle the strings, you
can have as many languages
as your community wants to do.
And then you can see
if it's worth, then,
investing in having a proper
translation done down the line.
So if you've got the community,
I think it's worth doing.
BOB MEESE: Any other
questions out there?
AUDIENCE: We're taking about
translation and localization.
BOB MEESE: Want to pass it over?
AUDIENCE: We're talking about
localization and translation.
And I wanted to ask if you
do just the text localization
where you keep the voiceover
and the original in English,
for instance?
Or do you do both, or
like a complete package?
And if it's actually
worth doing just the text
and then having the voiceover
in English, whether it's
having actually a worse
impact than just leaving it
in English?
ANATOLY ROPOTOV:
So at Game Insight,
we have a title called
"Tank Domination," which
came out earlier this year.
We launched it at GDC.
And it features Michael Ironside
from "Starship Troopers,"
a famous US actor out there.
And he voiceovered that for US.
For Russia, we used
a different person
who does VO for a lot of movies,
and he's kind of a famous star.
And then we would have
a similar approach
for a lot of our trailers
and a lot of our content.
If you have that,
you definitely have
to think from a
marketing perspective
how you could leverage the power
of famous voices, famous actors
on a region-by-region
basis, whether it
could make a significant
impact and how
you could make that a part
of your marketing strategy.
And we found out that
it's really worth
that, because endorsements
of celebrities, as you know
from a lot of recent
launches by other companies,
are very powerful, so you
definitely have to do that,
yeah.
EYAL RABINOVICH: We have
a game in the pipeline.
Not out yet, but hopefully
you hear about it.
And it's very voice-intensive.
You have a lot of text
and a lot of voice.
And it creates some kind
of a unique experience.
But I think that we
are then definitely
going to have to go for
the full localization.
Even some modification in the
storyline might have to happen.
So, like everything,
I think it kind of
depends on the
content in a game.
And you have to consider
everything case by case.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
Can I just--
EYAL RABINOVICH: Jeez.
OK.
It would be probably
for Antonin,
because we are producing
a shooter as well.
And so basically,
the question, OK,
is should we just translate?
We're a team of 21 people.
So we don't have the resources.
So does it make sense to
just translate the text
and leave the rest in
English, the voiceover?
ANTONIN LHUILLIER: Yeah,
I think it makes sense.
There are some
games from Gameloft
where you have
very sophisticated
English voiceovers with
the voices from the actors,
of all the ponies from the
ponies in "My Little Pony,"
for instance, and
we don't localize.
There are subtitles.
So I think for a shooter,
the main pleasure
that players will take from the
shooter is to actually shoot
in the action scene.
So if you make some good
sound effects, it's fine.
Then they don't need
to be localized.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BOB MEESE: Can you
pass the mic over?
AUDIENCE: So China, done.
Korea, done.
Where are we going next, then?
Where's the next
market to go into?
Forget all this
localization stuff.
Where should I be
checking my game next?
Go on, let's have
a comment from you.
Chuck it.
SAAD CHOUDRI: Chuck it.
All right.
That's the question I was going
to ask of the panel anyway.
What's next?
For us we see a
lot in Indonesia.
People have talked
about Indonesia.
We see a lot in Turkey.
Brazil is quite
well-known as well.
The Middle East.
I think Saudi Arabia,
UAE, Kuwait, Bahrain,
those countries,
traditionally a lot of you
probably will have very
high-spending users there.
But we've never really
culturalized in those regions.
We've never really created games
that cater to that audience
and really support
those audiences.
One of the things, people
talk about seasonal updates,
like Valentine's Day not
meaning anything in Korea.
One of the things
that we did is we
supported Pakistan
Independence Day.
And I'm not saying that because
my heritage is from there,
but we did that because we
have a big audience there.
And it really engaged
the community.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAAD CHOUDRI: No, no.
Community support We
had people out there,
and not just the flag.
We did other things.
Did--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAAD CHOUDRI: Well,
of course, you're
going to do that as well, right?
But it's an easy win.
But that's what we have
to do in emerging markets
where you're not really going
to see a financial return.
But you know that actually
it's going to be a burgeoning
community, and they stay there.
And they push the game for
you, and they help you,
and you get power
users from there.
So everybody's probably going
to roll out a beta program soon.
People in these communities
or in other locations
provide very valuable feedback.
And there's a great
talent pool to see.
So I think Middle
East, Africa-- we're
seeing quite a bit in Nigeria--
and then Vietnam, as well,
is coming up for us as well.
JOE RAEBURN: So just
one really quick thing.
If you want to avoid
pain, avoid flags.
Flags are a symbol of
political division.
We put flags in our game.
We put a few of them.
We didn't put every
single country in there.
People get really angry
when their country is not
represented.
When we put Hong Kong in
there, we had quite a few
high-spending ethnically
Chinese-living-in-America
gamers coming
together to say, look,
these are the alliances
that we represent.
And we're all going to quit
the game until and unless you
remove the Hong Kong flag.
There's just grief all the time.
So unless you want to
maintain every single flag
for every single nation and
have selective hiding of flags--
like you should
probably hide the Tibet
one for Chinese audiences
as well-- just avoid
a world of pain.
You think they're
such a nice thing that
will make everybody happy.
They won't.
Indonesia as well is
becoming quite hard-core.
We have quite a few
Indonesian alliances
in our game, one
of the top three.
Once we offered a special deal
to quite a few of our players,
and the Indonesian
alliance didn't get it
because they didn't quite
have the spend level required.
They called the Indonesian
chef that lives at London.
He dropped by our
office, knocked,
and he said he wouldn't
leave until we offered them
a special deal.
So they're pretty hard-core.
They're really great
gamers, and we're
going to be localizing our
next game into Indonesia, too.
EYAL RABINOVICH: Same question?
BOB MEESE: Or something else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
EYAL RABINOVICH: [INAUDIBLE].
BOB MEESE: Little
bit more time, too.
We have about five
more minutes overall.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
What can we do in India?
ANTONIN LHUILLIER:
I was about actually
to say India about what's next,
because there's only one where
we probably see a higher
penetration of the PlayStore
in India.
So then, of course,
I think it's about 5%
of the population
that speaks English.
And then you have a lot
of different languages.
So I guess we will
follow that closely.
And we will see how this market
goes, and how you go there,
and what billing options
you add, and so on.
So it's probably
the next territory.
ANATOLY ROPOTOV: Yeah, I
think the next big challenge
is figure out how to monetize
players in those regions, where
they just couldn't pay with
cards and things like that.
So definitely more
alternative payment methods,
rolling out prepaid cards with
general availability out there,
figuring out things
like price scaling.
Not every country has
should have $19.99 option
to pay for your
game, because you
have to go into smaller
increments and steps out there
and figure out
how to incentivize
those players to use
new payment methods,
try them, using wire, SMS,
direct billing, and things
like that.
So it's the next big
challenge for those countries,
for game developers to
really pay attention
to just figure out how
to actually get revenues
from there.
Because nowadays, a
lot of those countries
could be only monetized
decently by ads,
because you couldn't
just collect money there.
So as soon as more
payment options,
as soon as a culture of
payment would roll out,
we'll see a lot of things.
Actually, look, I've
tried a lot of experiments
in those countries.
So sometimes we would say even
like 10,000 crystals for price
point of $0.10.
And we would just see
that people don't even
react to that offer
because they don't
know the ways of payments.
They just don't have cards
and things like that.
It flags-- like we will have
to figure out how to get there
and how to fix those
problems along what
was from the platform side
and the developer side,
or from price scaling, and
explaining those payment plans.
BOB MEESE: You want to
finish this off here, Saad?
SAAD CHOUDRI: I'm going
to finish this off, yeah.
Binary size, it's important.
Data, Android One, supporting
those low-memory devices,
that's going to be
crucial for these regions.
I think the payment
processes will come.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAAD CHOUDRI: There is.
There is, actually.
I was going to say--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
It's just not there at all.
How are you going
to accept money
from those guys [INAUDIBLE]?
BOB MEESE: Right.
So it's certainly coming.
So we are increasingly
prioritizing
by strategic market.
Obviously, credit card
has been available,
but we've added
direct-carrier billing
in 26 countries, gift cards
in 22, PayPal now in 12.
Other forms of payment are
being looked into as well.
In India, it's very
much a cash economy.
We can't quite directly
accept cash through the phone,
but we would if we could.
But we're looking at
a variety of options.
Because, yeah, to
the extent that you
have really compelling markets
that are just held back
by that one issue,
it's something
that's very actively
being explored.
SAAD CHOUDRI: And are you guys
being aggressive on the revenue
shares with the carriers?
BOB MEESE: Can't talk
about those things.
SAAD CHOUDRI: So we won't know.
BOB MEESE: Yeah.
Cool.
But we should probably wrap.
But just thank you, guys, for
all the great insights here.
A lot of us are sticking
around, so either find us here,
find us in the back
with the drinks,
but just thank you all
for sticking around
through the day.